Y
FOR AMERICA'S NEW GOLDEN AGE.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US IS OHIO SENATE
CANDIDATE J.D. VANCE.
THIS AXIOS PIECE REALLY STRUCK
ME BECAUSE THE MEDIA ARE SEEING
THIS KIND OF GLOBALIST DREAM
WORLD BEGINNING TO FADE AWAY FOR
THEM BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE ARE ON
TO THIS TOTAL CHARADE.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS PLAYING OUT
WITH THIS NEW CROP OF
REPUBLICANS COMING INTO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> I THINK WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING FOR THE INCREASINGLY
WORKING AND MIDDLE-CLASS BASE OF
THE PARTY.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
DELIVERED IN A BIG WAY BUT AS
YOU KNOW HE WAS OFTEN NOT
ALIGNED WITH HIS OWN PARTY AND I
THINK WE REALLY WIN THE WAY WE
SHOULD IN '22 AND WE DELIVER
RESULTS, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
REPUBLICAN PARTY AT EVERY LEVEL
THAT IS ACTUALLY ALIGNED WITH
ITS OWN VOTERS AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE UNSTOPPABLE BECAUSE
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH ON TRADE,
IMMIGRATION, FIGHTING CHINA,
BRINGING AMERICAN MANUFACTURING
JOBS BACK, SECURING THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
WE CAN DO THE THINGS REPUBLICANS
HAVE PROMISED TO DO FOR A LONG
TIME BUT HAVE FAILED TO DO.
>> Laura: THIS NEW INSIGHT
FROM THE HILL THAT REPUBLICANS
ARE ACTIVELY COURTING HISPANIC
VOTERS IN KEY DISTRICTS TO PEEL
AWAY VOTERS FROM DEMOCRATS,
VOTERS ARE LIKELY TO PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN AT LEAST A DOZEN
DISTRICTS IN THE NOVEMBER
MIDTERMS.
YOU HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR THIS
AND I HAVE FOR A LONG TIME.
IT HAS LONG SINCE TIME IF THE
REPUBLICANS DID THE TYPE OF
MINORITY OUTRAGE WITH THE RIGHT
IDEA THAT THEY ARE FINALLY DOING
NOW.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
FOR SO LONG EVERYBODY TOLD US
THE WAY TO REACH THE HISPANIC
VOTE WAS TO GO SOFT ON BORDERS
AND IT TURNS OUT THE EXACT
OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
THE MORE WE LEAN INTO PROTECTING
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, THEM OR ME
LEAN INTO GIVING OUR POLICE
OFFICERS THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES, THE MORE
HISPANICS COME TO OUR SIDE.
THE ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS
AND ALSO THE LEFT SHARE THIS
ASSUMPTION THAT IDENTITY
POLITICS WAS THE WAY TO REACH
OUT TO LATINOS.
IT TURNS OUT THE WAY TO REACH
OUT TO LATINOS IS BE NORMAL.
NOT BE A CRAZY PERSON.
ACTUALLY TALK TO THEM IN A WAY
THAT SERVES THEIR INTERESTS AND
APPEAL TO THOSE INTERESTS.
THAT'S SIMPLE OLD-FASHIONED
POLITICS AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT.
>> Laura: THE SO-CALLED
DEMOCRAT POPULISTS, THE ONE WHO
CLAIMED TO BE FOR THE WORKING
PEOPLE, WE SEE THIS WITH THE
SQUAD AND SO FORTH.
THEY NEVER HELP THE WORKING
PEOPLE.
STACEY ABRAMS WHO WANTS TO OF
COURSE TAKE OUT BRIAN KEMP IN
GEORGIA, IT TURNS OUT THAT SHE
IS GETTING BLOCKBUSTER
FUND-RAISING NUMBERS FROM
OUT-OF-STATE MONEY.
HER CAMPAIGN AND LEADERSHIP
COMMITTEE HAVE REPORTED
RECEIVING ABOUT $7 MILLION FROM
GEORGIA DONORS.
THAT'S ONLY 14% OF THE NEARLY
50 MILLION THEY HAVE COMBINED TO
RAISE THIS CYCLE.
IT TURNS OUT THE PLUTOCRAT'S
LOVE STACEY ABRAMS.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
WHAT DO THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO GET FROM HER.
>> THEY DO AND THEY LOVE
TIM RYAN, MY DEMOCRAT OPPONENT
IN OHIO.
THE THING THE DEMOCRATS DO IF
YOU LOOK AT THEIR RECORD, THEY
ARE ALIGNED WITH BIG TECH, LINED
WITH BIG FINANCE.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY ALIGNED WITH
THE PEOPLE DESTROYING AMERICA'S
ENERGY SECTOR WHICH HURTS THE
WORKING AND MIDDLE-CLASS
PRESIDENT HURTS ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THESE PEOPLE
HAVE A TON OF MONEY FROM THESE
OUT-OF-STATE DONORS.
MY OPPONENT TIM RYAN HAS GOT
SOMETHING LIKE 90% OF HIS MONEY
HAS COME FROM OUTSIDE THE STATE
OF OHIO.
PEOPLE CAN GO TO J.D.Vance.com
IF YOU WANT TO HELP US FIGHT
BACK.
THIS MONEY IS THE ONE THING THAT
COULD BLUNT OF A RED WAVE AND
IT'S NOT JUST A RED WAVE BUT
IT'S THE RIGHT KIND OF
REPUBLICANS COMING INTO D.C.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY FIX THE
PROBLEM AND FIGHT BACK ONCE AND
FOR ALL.
>> Laura: I UNDERSTAND
TIM RYAN IS ALSO JUST ABUSING
THE PROXY VOTING THAT
NANCY PELOSI IS STILL IN A
MIND-BOGGLING WAY ALLOWING ON
CAPITOL HILL.
NO ONE IS ESSENTIAL.
THEY NEVER HAVE TO SHOW UP AND
WORK ON CAPITOL HILL BUT
MR. POPULIST SHIRTSLEEVES GUY
WHO'S GOING TO HELP THE REGULAR
PERSON CAN'T ACTUALLY SHOW UP IN
WASHINGTON TO DO HIS JOB.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WORSE.
HIM SHOWING UP TO DO HIS JOB OR
NOT SHOWING UP TO DO HIS JOB.
BUILDING WAS JOE BIDEN 100% OF
THE TIME.
IT'S HILARIOUS THAT A GUY WHO
CLAIMS TO SPEAK FOR WORKING
PEOPLE IS CLAIMING TWO YEARS
AFTER THE PANDEMIC THAT COVID
PREVENTS HIM FROM SHOWING UP AND
DOING HIS JOB.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT'S A FARCE.
AGAIN, THAT'S THE DEMOCRATIC
POPULIST.
THEY ARE ALL ABOUT IDENTITY
POLITICS, DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
THEY ARE FAKE.
THEY ARE NOT PURSUING POPULIST
ISSUES.
THEY JUST WANT TO PUT ON THE
POPULIST GARB, RAISE THE MONEY
AND HOPEFULLY GET POWER SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
AMERICAN OLIGARCHY INSTEAD OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: A VOTE FOR TIM RYAN
IS A VOTE TO KEEP NANCY PELOSI A